there's this myth the market goes up the
market goes down that's not really true
so how do i know who the person is
to help me build my wealth plan like how
do i identify that person
stay disciplined keep investing focus on
the long run
you know really wealthy people are not
watching financial media around the
clock and making moves based on that
so people are just trying to time the
market and they end up losing
that's exactly right
ladies and gentlemen we have a true
legend in the house here mr peter maluk
if you don't know his name yet
he has written two books with this guy
mr tony robbins if you have read
the best-selling book unshakable you'll
see here at the bottom with peter maluk
and in the sub headline here is
ranked the number one wealth advisor in
the u.s for three consecutive years by
barons
he started creative planning uh which
manages 55
billion dollars in assets if you can
believe that's crazy and he's got a new
book out with tony called the path which
is going to help you accelerate your
journey to
financial freedom peter maluk welcome
aboard man hey good to be with you evan
so you've worked with so many successful
people
the riches of the rich who have figured
out financial freedom
what do they know that the average joe
doesn't know about getting financial
freedom i think the average joe thinks
that it's a system that can be gamed
like everything else and i think what
really wealthy people have figured out
is it's really about
discipline and a pattern putting money
away in a disciplined way no matter
what's going on
in various asset classes and letting
time work
on your side so i think about it like
the reverse of gambling
like most people when they go to a
casino and gamble some people think they
can beat that casino if they learn
everything but really if you play
perfectly the odds are you're going to
lose and
the longer you play the longer the odds
you're going to lose
well investing if you do it right you're
the house you're the casino
you might lose on any given day uh dodge
you invest in the stock market and you
lose in one day is about 50 50.
but if you're invested for a year the
odds you win or 75
if you're invested for three years it's
about 93
and so what wealthy people have figured
out is it's time is your friend
so stay disciplined keep investing focus
on the long run
you know really wealthy people are not
watching financial media around the
clock and making moves based on that
it's interesting what you just said
because a lot of people would think that
putting money in the stock market is
gambling
yeah that's the narrative for a lot of
america so you just said
no it's not it's you're the house so
just break that down for us explain a
little more well i think that
there's this myth the market goes up the
market goes down that's not really true
uh it's like saying the casino wins the
casino loses the casino wins or loses on
any given hand or any given spin of the
roulette wheel
but over time the casino wins and over
time the market goes up so
the longer you're in the market the more
you have that on your side so let's just
take a horrible investor
they invested the day before covet
started they're positive today
if they invested uh before 9 11 they're
positive today before the tech bubble
before 809 and not a little bit positive
they've doubled or tripled their money
over some of those entry points if
you're the worst investor in the world
invested before some of those terrible
events eventually the market moves up
and
you know we can relate that with the
products the stock market is
representative of products apple we have
our iphone and everything else
and with mcdonald's we can get a meal
and with
netflix we get the streaming service and
we know like if we buy a hershey's bar
today
that it will probably cost more 10 years
from now it certainly cost more to buy a
hershey's bar today than 10 years ago or
20 years ago but we don't
have confidence that hershey's stock is
going to go up you know
we we should look at and go if we expect
this can of diet coke to go up in
value if it's going to cost more 10
years from now to buy than today well it
makes sense that coca-cola stock will
probably follow
and so we we don't have a problem
understanding how
the market the economy expands in terms
of pricing and inflation but we seem to
think the market goes up and down
it's on a journey up and it takes pauses
on the way up it doesn't go up in a
straight line but it just
heads that way over the long run so
people are just trying to time the
market and they end up losing
that's exactly right so one of the ways
that you lose is your time so
one of the record flow for outflows from
the stock market this year was
in march so when the market was doing
its worst
people took money out of the market and
they went and bought bonds
and what a mess because the market's up
you know 30 40
since then s p 500 recovered all of its
losses
so someone timing that really made a
mistake and sometimes timing is not that
dramatic
sometimes it's as simple as hey i don't
want to
uh invest now because i think the
election i need to wait for the election
or i'm waiting until 2021 i'm wait till
coronavirus is gone
all of those things are market timing
and so
they're all dangerous that that moving
in and out like that all of those moves
are dangerous
the market has this upward trend and if
you get in the way of that you're more
likely to cause harm than good
i think people are also very fear driven
they don't understand the markets they
feel like i didn't go to school for this
i don't have a background in this i
worked hard for this money and i don't
want it
to risk losing it what do you suggest
for somebody where where are they
putting it is it finding the right
planner is it buying an etf is it
picking your favorite stock
is it throwing something at the
dartboard like that's probably not your
advice
what what am i doing what are we doing
to get started i think if somebody's
starting out they don't they they just
got some money they have a few hundred
dollars or a few thousand dollars
you should open an account at a place
like charles schwab or fidelity or
vanguard
and go buy an index fund go buy the s p
500
that's 500 stocks uh big u.s companies
think of nike mcdonald's
google you wind up owning a big basket
of about 500 of those companies
really representative of the national
economy and
you're just buying one thing you're
buying one index and you get
all 500 or so of those stocks so you get
diversified across different industries
uh different types of businesses and
over time that will work for you about
three out of four years will be positive
but over 10 years it will
almost certainly be positive and do
better than your alternatives like
buying bonds or cds or staying in cash
and when does it make sense for someone
to go to an advisor
for extra help so i think like no matter
how young you are it makes sense to go
pay an
advisor by the hour and get some advice
on laying out a road map
because really the biggest gift an
investor can have is
time is somebody who's investing when
they're in their 20s or 30s is so much
better off
than someone who's investing in their
50s they can they can invest
one-fourth the amount and come out ahead
because they've got time on their side
so if you can get some advice early from
somebody knows what they're doing about
how to set up a roth ira what to
contribute to a roth ira what
investments to buy what you should do
with your 401k
that advice is it's the bet the earlier
you get it the better
but you probably don't need to be paying
for extremely sophisticated ongoing
management
until you get 50 000 100 000 or more you
can benefit from owning a lot of
different things
and so talk about that so somebody's got
50 100k or maybe a little more
they're not in the billions yet you know
it might be their aspiration to be able
to retire with something
good what what what does the investment
advisor help them with that's more
active
at the 50 100k that's going to actually
make a big difference for them
so now you're going to own different
asset classes we need more than just the
s p 500 so we're going to maybe look at
having a global portfolio it might make
sense to own bonds it might make sense
to own real estate
you have enough money that someone
should be taking advantage of tax trades
like if the market drops selling things
that are down and replacing them you can
you can come up with the same return
but wind up with a deduction on your tax
return
they might rebalance the portfolio which
means selling things doing well and
buying things doing poorly for you at
times you might not have the discipline
or time to do yourself so for example
you know in march of this year our
company creative planning was
selling bonds and client portfolios and
buying stocks while the stock
market was down so the stock market
recovers our clients have more of that
and they're able to get ahead than just
holding through all of that as he
starts to make sense to have those extra
things to give you a little bit of an
edge
how much of asset allocation for you is
market timing versus
that client's position in life and how
much of
a window they have in this tolerance let
me asset allocation is all about you
know what are you trying to accomplish
so
i for for your viewers basically asset
allocation is
of your investments of your assets how
are you going to allocate them what are
you going to put in the u.s what are you
going to put overseas where are you
going to put in bonds what do you put in
stocks
probably the biggest decision in all of
asset allocation is what goes to stocks
versus what goes to bonds
and bonds really have very low long-term
returns especially now when interest
rates are so low
and so you really need to get where you
want to go you've got to own more stocks
but if you've got somebody who's
retiring in a year or two they can't be
all stocks because stuff happens your
coronavirus 911 whatever the market can
get
cut in half for any reason at any time
so you have to have something in
short-term investments or safe
investments
whether it's bonds or something bond
like to make sure those short-term needs
can get met
but otherwise you really want stocks for
the longer run so i'm really a believer
in doing things based on need
not based on age or risk tolerance not
really saying we're gonna have this much
bonds and stocks because you're
not a risky person or because you're
you're 32 or 52
instead of saying how much do you have
how much are you saving
when do you need to take this money out
is that going to change and then picking
the investments
that have the highest chance of meeting
those needs over time
and when you've got an entrepreneur so
most of my audience is going to be
entrepreneurs want to be entrepreneurs
established entrepreneurs
cash is often tight cash is often going
into our baby our business trying to get
it to the next
yeah at what point do you recommend
like some strategies right is it at the
beginning put everything in your
business is it once you start making
money puls
pull a certain piece out is it from the
beginning save 10 and put into something
like what rules of thumb would you have
for
new entrepreneurs you know so what every
entrepreneur wants to accomplish
is to be free to do whatever they want
whenever they want to do it
and so they try to like invest in their
business and do whatever they want but
they try to build a pool of money on the
side
then no matter what happens they're set
their family set for the rest of their
life so the dream
scenario for an entrepreneur is if they
need you know 100 000 a year to
to live adjusted for inflation they
might try to get a 2 million portfolio
built up on the side
so that whatever is happening in the
world with them they can keep taking
risks and doing all these dynamic things
knowing they're secure it takes a long
time to build that pile up
but it doesn't take a lot of money if
you're starting you know earlier
so i always encourage entrepreneurs like
you know the way it works entrepreneur
world is things go great or things blow
up i know i'm an entrepreneur i've had
lots of businesses fail and
and a few succeed and you need to have
some kind of security behind you
that enables you to take those risks
with a little bit of a hammock
you know behind you if something goes
sideways so do you have a rule of thumb
of a percent of
income or revenue that we should be
pulling aside no for me it's more about
what are you trying to what what what is
it going to take for you to be secure
and what do we have to do on a monthly
basis to create that pool
and so if if somebody's really got a hot
hand right now and they're making a lot
of money and
maybe don't deploy all of it maybe put
30 40 away if you're really struggling
that you don't kill yourself you know
put away a small amount
but try to be disciplined and always
have something going off to that
diversity bucket because ultimately
all money is a means to an end whether
it's your business that you're
launching or that's mature or this pool
of money
the point is to give you security and to
do the freedom
the freedom of what you want to do is
pay for your future kids school
take care of your family if you're gone
enjoy yourself in retirement pay for a
wedding
and so we have to have different
approaches we can't all
be all in on the business only if you're
an entrepreneur you'll never just be
satisfied
with the portfolio but look at what you
can take without compromising your
business
uh off to the side to make progress
towards being independent
outside of your business got it so
everybody the book is called the path
accelerating your journey to financial
freedom for the youtube audience we'll
link that in the description below you
can go pick up your copy
for people who are if you talk about
financial freedom i mean everybody
everybody wants it because nobody's
gonna say i don't i don't need financial
freedom
is it a lack of information
a lack of discipline a lack of belief
like what's the big problem you think
i think there's a lack of everything so
i think first of all we have a
we have a lot of information it's just
not good information so we have more
information than ever before at our
fingertips
uh and so it becomes hard to say oh you
know all i got to do is put away a small
amount every month and buy a couple of
indexes and
when i get to a certain level hire an
advisor it's too simple we're flooded
with thousands of pieces of information
that tell us it must be much more
complicated than that and i've got to be
doing fancier things or crazier things
or investing in my friend's idea and all
of those things
and really it's not it's not finding
information it's getting all this noise
all this excess information away from
you and focusing only on the things that
matter i really tried to cover that in
the path
where you know with tony robbins he and
i write about
here are the things to focus on here are
the building blocks if you do these
things
go do whatever else you want to do but
take care of these things
and you'll be in great shape i love it
so you're an author now you know i mean
you've
i know you had one book a number of
years ago but you've kind of been heads
down building your business and
and i mean massive success 55 billion
dollars
assets under management with a crazy
number
why write books like what's the why
behind this book this is not
you know massively paying the bills so
right right books what's the incentive
well i mean the first one i wrote was
five mistakes every investor makes and
how to avoid them and it was really just
hey here are my thoughts on the stock
market it was all about all the things
we're talking about
how to look at the market how to invest
in the market how to get diversified
avoid the mistakes like timing
uh and then tony and i wrote unshakeable
which you showed earlier which was also
all about the markets
but the reality is there's more to
investing than the markets there's also
all these other issues like tax planning
and how to set up a business
and how to get money to uh your family
in the best way possible how to make a
charitable gift the smartest way
possible do you need insurance
so i wrote the path um to talk about
that to say look it's not just about the
money which we wrote about last time
it's about all these aspects of wealth
management not just how to grow it but
how to protect it and how to transfer it
uh and everything in between and so the
path is more a playbook to wealth
management
more the way a wealthy person or someone
who aspires to be wealthy looks at
things
money management how you manage your
money and your investments is just a
piece
of overall wealth management as your
viewers know i mean part of it's
the big part of it's your business and
some of it's your house and all these
other pieces go together
and that's what we cover in the past so
if i'm
you know under 50k i'm i'm buying the
etf i'm buying the market
i'm trying to save as much as i can to
have my nest egg kind of built up
when i'm ready to make that jump i'm in
that 1500k range or maybe a little bit
above
how do i know who to pick how do i
everybody talks in fancy language and
it's complicated and i think it's so
much fear in the system and i know i
know
tony you you go against a lot of people
in this book
you know tearing down the mutual fund
industry and all of that like
we've been taught that mutual funds are
good so so how do i
know who the person is to help me
build my wealth plan like how do i
identify that person
so basically what we want to do is we
want to find somebody who doesn't have
their own products to sell so the
financial services industry is really
interesting like we would never go to a
doctor
who owns five medications and prescribes
those medications all the time
but that is how financial services works
you pay somebody a percentage of what
they're managing
and most advisors work for a company
that then has their own investment
products to sell you whether it's their
own mutual funds or alternative
investments
so that's an inherent conflict of
interest and we want to avoid you want
to avoid that you're
more likely to get a better outcome if
that conflict doesn't exist so to really
avoid that conflict
it helps to get an independent advisor
so
there's there's basically two kinds of
advisors there's a broker
and then there's an independent advisor
and working with an independent advisor
really
improves the probability you've got
someone who has to be on your side of
the table all the time and isn't just
going to sell you
an investment product so are there other
questions
i should ask i mean one uh do you make
any money from the things that
that you're selling is a good starting
point is like how else
i think just people are afraid you don't
know what to do
these people in the suits look like they
know what they're talking about and
they're driving the fancy cars so they
know something about money and all i
know is how to build my business
like how else do i filter when i don't
have domain expertise
in financial services well i think one
big thing is competence
is your if you're getting planning is
the person a certified financial planner
or is there a certified financial
planner on the team like at our
company there's a certified financial
planner on every team because we think
someone's going to be giving financial
planning advice to you they should be
trained
and they have a designation in it uh the
second is conflict you know avoiding
working with somebody who makes more
money selling you one investment
over another uh the other is custody you
don't ever want to give your money to
somebody like if you're working with us
at creative planning we hold our clients
money to third party like a fidelity or
charles schwab
that way you don't have to worry about
the murder bernie madoff situation
whereas
if a friend is buying a strip mall and
you go give that friend
uh money that friend can then put it in
their checking account and take it and
you're not going to know
right and so giving up custody of your
money can be dangerous
uh too so focusing on things like
competence
conflict custody that really narrows it
down to where you're only looking at a
few percent
of the advisors and it becomes easier to
make a decision
got it going down the path of
diversification a little bit
a lot of entrepreneurs when they're
starting are starting to think of
multiple streams of income and a lot of
people end up trying to build
you know 10 multiple streams of income
but none of them are
paying off because they're just their
time is split too much
yeah do you think investing is it do you
think it's better than just entrepreneur
advice is it better to start one
business
and focus on it and then take the money
out to then diversify
through the markets well i think the
business owners entrepreneurs they get
this bug to start all kinds of
businesses
and it's usually a mistake usually if
you have an entrepreneur and they're
running three or four things there's one
that
really really shows promise and makes a
lot of sense
and but they're spending maybe 25
percent of their time on four things
they should be spending 100
on one find the business where you're
the most competitive the most passionate
that's the one where you should be
investing all your time and talent
and and treasure to make it get going
and then build a diversified portfolio
on the side but try not to
dilute your time and commitment to your
business by opening
other ones that don't contribute to your
bottom line as much
and i kind of how i hear you're saying
it is when i'm
making my investment choices i'm
diversified but i'm not having to spend
a lot of my focus or energy on it
because i'm either buying the market
when i'm really staged i'm buying
everything
or i'm giving it to a trusted advisor
and they're running with it because
they're the expert
so i just have faith that it's going to
grow and i can focus my efforts back on
my business
that's right when you're investing the
portfolio forget about it and get get
back to focusing your attention
in your real wealth generator which is
your day job
what's the question or line of thinking
that kind of drives you the most nuts in
this industry
uh the line of thinking that drives me
the most nuts i think that
complexity is a key to success i think
the key to success
is really to make things as simple as
possible and get those things done so
for example
you don't need a big complex insurance
plan even if you're a business owner you
probably don't need permanent life
insurance or whole life insurance you
don't need an expensive policy
you probably need the cheapest easiest
insurance to get which is term insurance
policy which
would pay to your to your family or your
partners if something happened to you
and it costs
very very little insurance agents don't
make a lot of money on it and that's why
they tend not to sell it so the simplest
thing
is the right solution same when it comes
to investing in the stock market
the simplest thing is to buy an index
it's also happens to be the best option
so i the big big problem in our
industries
is everything's made to be much more
complex than it needs to be
and really the good news for your
viewers is hey you're focused on your
job and that's where your attention
should be
just know the fundamentals and do those
fundamentals with your diversified
portfolio and you'll be on the right
track
so for people who pick up the path and
again youtube link it in the description
below it's called the path
peter malouk tony robbins um what do you
hope
is the action item that people take away
because that's you know you write a book
you want people to learn obviously but
then to do something so what do you hope
is the action item they do
after reading your book first i hope
that when they read it they go wow this
is
you know peter and tony did a good job
of really simplifying things for me i
really understand this and i know what
to do so i'm just hoping that they feel
like i finally get this
and i know the four or five things i
need to do to get my personal situation
in order
and then i hope they go do those things
i hope they open the account and invest
the type of investments we encourage
them to
that they protect against uh risks of
disability and death and things that we
talk about in the book that they
get basic estate planning done like a
healthcare power of attorney that says
who would make health care decisions for
you if you couldn't make them for
yourself
and really they can get all that stuff
done pretty quickly and they'll be in a
much much better position than they were
before they read the path
got it um i know we're kind of coming up
against the clock maybe just a final
message for people who are watching this
who they've been putting this off
because they're afraid it sounds complex
it sounds like all these terms that they
don't want to think about but they know
they kind of need to otherwise they
won't
live that financial freedom life and
they're tired of they're like on the
on the rat race of trying to bring money
in all the time
what piece of advice would you give them
to kind of push them over the edge to
say no this is important for you right
now
i think it's basically you think about
in your business you spend
thousands of hours trying to get it
where it needs to be in any given year
and we're talking about here maybe
dedicating five hours
set the fruits of all of this time that
you spent
coming up with idea investing in
building your business leading people
coming up with a product trying to
compete those
thousands and thousands of hours for
some it's tens of thousands of hours
now you spent five hours going what do i
do with the fruits of this
i think it's five hours i can't imagine
getting a better return on your
investment uh than that i love it peter
maluk in the house the book is called
the path
accelerating your journey to financial
freedom check it out the link below
peter thank you for the time man the
knowledge the care it's been awesome
having you here
thanks adam appreciate you if you want
to see the one-on-one i did with
tony robbins check it out right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there tony welcome aboard man
thanks evan great to be with you